If you're watching this,
that means today is the last day for
early bird registration for the jubilee
private conference live for something
greater that needs today's the last day
you can get to this kind of price.
So go and register now at jubilee project,
a org slash conference. We have an
amazing set of speakers for you,
including folks like PK, Jen from head
to toe, fill you from angry Asian man,
and so many more that we
haven't even announced.
It's going to be an incredible
conference that will change your life.
So go register now. Tell your
friends, tell your family,
bring your dog. Actually,
I don't think he can bring your dog,
but bring your friends and we'll see
you soon. Doing good. It's contagious.